i almost got eaten yesterday by a bear
bear wanted to eat me and the bear was
like right next to the
the glass but thankfully it was pretty
thick glass
so yeah this is a stare of a bear who
wants to eat you
keep zooming in
uh and then i took some video
and then all of a sudden
yeah here we go
it's probably the closest i've ever been
to a bear
could be more relaxing to to watch chess
sometimes let's play a london
okay it's going to be london time if g6
i play knight c3
i still have to post my match with
davina uh on to youtube
because we had a very london themed
match
um it's very educational
okay this is mainline different ways
black can play here
i think a lot of people these days are
casting and playing queen c7
after which i'll take okay this is like
the main main line
bishop b5 is carlson's choice of move
um yeah we're following a game carlson
beaucoc
oh i remember wait divina played this
against me i think
in our our uh small match and then what
did i do i played 95 which is not the
engine move but it's
kind of the most understandable move
if ever it takes i'm happy to get the h
file
otherwise um yeah keeping some tension
thank you who's that
raw thor dwarf
sorry for butchering names i was just
watching your stream from earlier today
when someone asked if you were going to
play arena king
and you are playing arena kings oh good
timing
ah my my heat just came on hey it's
chass dojo
just dojo thanks for the raid um
my heat just came on but it shouldn't
affect the audio so much
so okay b6
i'm pretty sure sam shanklin was just
streaming on chessdojo
doing some high level lesson
okay i got the focus here e4 is a move
and we trade we trade some more
uh let's do it also
knight sorry more five thank you for
gifting five subs
and mr matt five also subbing okay i'll
be right back
okay this is 3-0 right this is 3-0
also chess boy rd gifting to minku83
yeah i appreciate all the love and
support
uh and thanks for the bits pie hole
okay so the center is occupied
pieces are not social distancing
i feel like players who are new to chess
would have a very hard time like
internalizing what's going on in this
mess
but for a more experienced player like
you kind of see how everything
is interrelated pressure against the
bishop so i'm threatening probably to
take
just get the bishop hair always have
ideas of this move hitting the queen
only
my bishop i might just win this game on
time actually i could throw in the check
um i probably don't want to
the takes takes it's a fork and i'm
still threatening to take and
fossilize the king
like right now i could take and
is it just meeting
it might just be mating
because if queen takes i check here
check here
oh no my rook and then check and then
mate
and same concept applies with bishop
there so black resigns okay
ozil starts very nice start
i'm in i'm in second place
i always forget which number is a
placing and which number is uh seating
but two two so i have two points and i'm
in second place
okay another london because it works so
well the first game
okay of course early on it's um a lot of
people are winning their games
um so there's going to be a big tie for
the lead
so this is another like very critical
london line
um queen b2 is more critical this
usually leads to
some pleasant happiness idea rook c1
yeah let's try and stay focused on the
game
i almost messed up truck b1 there
okay here i could take
which looks interesting
i was very brave of black to leave the
queen align with the rook
there's a fine line between bravery and
stupidity but
yeah black is making it work
if i i want to do crazy things but
i do have bishop e2 here
just questioning the existence of the
queen another idea is to play this in
this
if bishop here i never mind i think i'll
castle and play knight c4
i'm just going in for the
targeting of the weak square
i'm calculating uh takes tit never mind
we have this move
it's not winning anything just yet i
have this move too
this could be better
because i'm not only threatening oh do i
just get
forked okay
thankfully i think this is okay
i should not have allowed that but okay
now we trade
trade some more i might lose this pawn
and
oh that was really bad
yeah i just missed b5 okay
life goes on
um treat this as a gambit
95
so if takes i play rook a1 i want to
play g4
let there be eric oh that's me
thank you anoximander
okay yeah this is all london gone
terribly wrong
so we could end up trading everything
oh i'm preventing bishop d7 oh but
bishop b2 is possible there
okay oh f6 is possible then bishop c4
no i'm in trouble here again
um i don't know what to do
i mean i could give one spike check
oh i could take this way actually i
could um
play knight d6 so here i take
how bad is it
it's kind of bad it might just be
completely losing but maybe it's not
i'm still going to try and make black
work for it
calculation is never mind
so i have to save the rook let's just
move all the way back
rook defends the pawn so that would be
okay
play g3 here
i could come down to time scramble
so i'm hitting the rook wouldn't mind a
trade
check hitting the rook
again
f2 is weak i have this move
i mean this is survivable it's going to
watch my time
okay up on time now
i want to come around to g8
okay i can always guard a2 from behind
oh i missed takes on g6 oops
but it shouldn't matter because i'm
winning this
i feel kind of bad but okay
okay black was a little bit too slow
there so that's another win
um that's two out of two
top ten we have a queen's gambit
declined
then go for the casa corley variation
uh yeah this move white was finding this
92 is like the more common move that's
also playable
so it's this move if not here i play
this casting i play this
okay
um play this move
that's more about getting just a
pleasant structure
i know bishop g4 is some idea
start with this move
it's kind of weakening to the pawn but
i mean at some point we'll trade and
things should be okay
that's interesting if
ah that's probably a good move okay so
we could trade
i could maybe take and play b4
not sure
before there's e5
how to do this takes
i guess i could take and play
bishop d5
i'm just holding onto the pawn so white
has a kind of isolated pawn i have a
backwards pawn
so it should still be balanced
down a little bit of time some idea this
and this
maybe not
not sure how to attack this i guess this
and this
queen c5 might happen okay
it's probably a good move
i might play oh rookie 6 runs into
bishop f5
i'm not sure what my plan is maybe g6
king g7
just like slow gradual improvement
keep some time advantage
yeah that's a move bishop e6
it's unpleasant though
any rookie six here
just trying to defend
pieces are a little bit clunky still up
on time though
okay pressuring the e file
queen e7
opponent wants to play some rook h3
g5
yeah i'm going to be super safe it might
i might get smooshed but
sometimes you got to do what you got to
do
i have rook h82 a few ways to defend the
h-pawn
meanwhile i probably want to play this
move never mind
okay so plan this to play this and just
trade queens and
not get mated
uh yeah everything should be defended
f6 potential
f4 potential
so maybe i'll just move back idf6
really i guess that kind of works
rook b3 in the end we're trading
everything
so i calculated through rook b3 and i'll
be down the pawn but
white has all weak pawns also has
outside passer
but doesn't have much time
to attack the things
make this move
gotta move quicker
[Music]
um
that was just a time scramble
okay threatening meat
cutting meat again
okay
okay i feel bad but uh that's why time
is important
manage my time slightly better that game
okay three in a row let's go
grandmaster victory maybe stafford
gambit time
maybe not okay
my heart rate was high that game let's
play something solid but let's play
quick
so this is uh uh
what is this yeah let's play solid
so this is a vienna opening or bishop's
opening
blackout's a bishop pair have a little
bit less space but
it's not too bad i'd used to play this
in this
or first defend the pawn
preventing any knight g5 shenanigans
some point i might want to go for this
sort of aggressive idea
i don't think it works because 95 but it
might because i have neither four
let's try it so i'm threading a fork
yeah and now i probably just
go for that
there's queen d2 but then g5
it's getting sharp sharper
bishops versus knights actually i
usually prefer knights and faster time
controls but
bishops can be nice like heading towards
endgame
so now the rook's tied down to the
knight queen d2 will create the triple
battery then i play g5
there's cases where i lose a pawn but
i'll get compensation maybe
play bishop c8 probably
i could let's preserve the bishop hair
yeah i don't want to commit to g5 too
soon
i mean 92 i might have to play g5
queen h5 king g7
i think it's okay maybe f6
queen f7 eventually
even f5 could be interesting then queen
g7 aligned with the knight
that one's taking a lot of time
i've been watching like a decent amount
of hikaru
and one of the things that caro does
like even when he's in difficult
situations he just keeps moving quickly
which is something i'm trying to emulate
thank you salvik's the third
he's also able to just constantly talk
to twitch chat which is
sometimes harder to do
play this move probably end up taking
yeah i'm probably going to lose a pawn
but maybe not let me trade 94 rook d7
up a ton of time though holding on to d6
yeah position is very oh never mind
it's not very solid but it's actually
it's still kind of solid because here i
trade and then
i'll win the pawn bishop is actually it
holds everything together
two months streak love you eric i love
you too thank you
amp 1229. appreciate the love
yeah i'm probably not even worse here
like objectively because there's no open
there is one open file but it's not
really accessible
um that's a good idea i want to play b5
oh there's a cool concept
never mind
uh let's just play quickly
in this move
maybe this move
yeah and then i'll i mean i can just
kind of wait here
no rush now
um let's play this move
again plenty of time
but sometimes it's not just about
winning games it's about winning games
quickly and efficiently oh i'm playing
my um
my father i'll play e4
uh yeah because he played this against
me last time
he played c6 i think yeah i studied this
but do i remember it
yeah i'm nervous now
i forget my preparation h3 probably
oh yeah we played this last time what
did i prepare
i prepared this specifically but now i
forget everything
bishop e3 and bishop d3
yeah and last time i was supposed to
play a4
quicker but he knows what to do or
does he i have a5
yeah he's playing quicker than me okay
but i
i have a solid position i've already
spent so much time
man okay bishop here i have a6
i like the position pawns are weak no
offense to
hikaru's pawns
yeah i've come to learn if you insult
any anything that belongs
to her like the pawns and it can come
back to bite
you got it oh i'm trying
in this move position is really nice
um i just don't want to blunder anything
i also don't want to flag
keep the pressure maybe h5 h4 at some
point
uh it's tricky takes takes
oh wait it doesn't work though because i
can take on e8 first
and now i'm threatening a6 as well
yeah um
queen e2 maybe
queen e2 or bishop e4
might be safer
not what i wanted though
it's still pleasant the bishop here
so now i might want to sack
i have this move
and then f4 or no f4 doesn't work there
i thought that f4 worked
rookie 4
it's weird but i want to play f4 knight
oh no
i blundered my queen no
uh i'm still alive though king g2
he's gonna torture me though
okay everything's defended
oh he's gonna like torture flag me
life's not fair let's play this move
everything's still defended
ah not my pawn
i think the the only hope is to maybe go
for this like dumb stalemate trap
yeah let's set up this thing
no
i can't even set it up okay i resign ah
he's so good at chess
oh he's so good i had a nice position
and i laundered my queen
and then he tortured me and then nothing
no tricks worked in the end maybe if
there was increment i'd have
slightly better chances yeah good game
henkaru
okay i don't feel bad that's that's my
only loss so far
um i played a little bit too slowly like
he played quickly early on
and it was clear he wasn't playing super
accurately
so that was kind of my chance but
okay life goes on playing london
[Music]
halvard hf is a long time streamer
stop spy here from time to time
um let's play 95.
and then f4
okay i can't be too flustered still a
long tournament
i'm going to play aggressively this game
play queen d1
aligning preventing knight e4 which was
black's main idea
um yeah probably after the tournament
all i'll address chat maybe i'll do some
game analysis that's definitely a game i
should analyze
because um i was happy with the opening
happy with this opening too a lot of
pressure here
a lot of pressure i forgot i made tea
tea has been brewing for like 20 minutes
um drink tea eventually
okay so i could take and wait a minute
this move first
idea of lifting i have to get my my reps
in
thanks for the dad bits
okay um
yeah black has a lot of things defended
bishop e5 is a resource
oh oh there's a cool idea
but it requires
some niftiness i'm gonna play bishop b5
first the idea is to take and then play
this
it takes take sir rook g8 i think it
works
so i'm threatening made in one assume
takes and then this
move threatening queen h8 there's also
the possibility of taking
or wait a minute no i'm threatening this
too this is easier
yeah the bishop plays a key role here
thank you blender prone
uh black wasn't completely dead because
there was knight g6 there but it was
good
okay that was a nice game it was quick
uh london attacking win
underprone gifting five subs so
repeating the same lines
i've had this kind of similar variation
the third time so far
everyone's been playing knight e7 in a
slightly different line this time
so the threat is to take in queen a3 and
win a pawn
which is about to happen
right here there's knight here
okay so this is a nice opening trap let
me take my tea bag out
um probably takes with night and then
takes with pawn
so i'm drinking uh non-caffeinated it's
dandelion root tea
i'm sent to this by a viewer
it's nice nice kind of nighttime
chill tea um
yeah black's gonna get comp e5
uh f5 might come
yeah that's also playable probably put
the nylon f1
if i get the chance i want to play e4
do i use bags or leaves um i go back and
forth
um i do have a decent amount of like
higher quality loose leaf tea
maybe this move
but probably e4
yeah i just want to prevent black from
squeezing me
and if we trade then i get the knight to
d6 same case with d4
so black will probably leave the tension
but then if the e file opens i get
um a target yeah we'll take and play h3
bishop moves back i play this move
bishop moves
this way probably eventually before it
feels like to be a fetus
thank you for five months of great
content you great big slice of avocado
toast
i had avocado toast earlier today it was
actually had two slices had to slice
actually i didn't have to slice the
bread but i did slice avocado
thank you mr kilo slowly becoming a baby
if i play this there's this move
and then if i take the g5 trapping my
knight
but i think what i'll do is play knight
d4
or okay yeah now i play b4
now my queen can come to a happier place
maybe take the pawn
it's a immediate threat
sorry if the mic was not in my face
enough
sometimes i'm like like gets pointed
downwards and
but hopefully it's okay uh rook b1 looks
normal
let me move back so
very least i can play e3 very most maybe
knight d4
let's start with a3 this pawn is still
hanging by the way
leigh g4 is intriguing takes takes
it's a way to simplify okay i have to
save the rook first
yeah this is a super solid structure i
think they're in uh in drops they call
this a fork
um it's like a cool solid formation
in chess we just call it i don't even
know what we call it
looks like a dinosaur kind of
okay let's be sneaky
also thank you chess boy rd gifting to
mr philo
play this move so now of g5
i um i have queen h5 rookie shade is
kind of a bigger problem which i forgot
about
i might have to go slightly insane
but only slightly oh no my knight
so i'm winning pawns up a ton of time
and probably not even worse here because
the bishop's attacked
bishop moves somewhere i have queen c4
yeah now we can simplify
simplify further
okay that was nice another nice kind of
london
grind down wind nice kind of opening
trap too
from early on so thank you low on ranch
welcome back
oh i said i was gonna try this this one
trap
which isn't working sadly thanks for all
your content eric
good luck in the tour oh it is working
isn't it
yeah like king should be safe here i
think it might kind of backfire
but oh wait a minute is this all prepped
from white
wow what just happened
am i losing i can't take and if i take
this way i got forked
but then i check and
that's so weird
i have to try this i'm
kind of getting punished though
i don't know what to make of this what
is this opening
maybe we're just inventing new london
theory
uh yeah a good move
wait it's not so bad though or is it
so i take and then
i have to hold on to the h pawn queen f3
is coming
queen f3 kg7
i guess this is the way to go oh queen
f3 knight f7
[Music]
oh i could have taken the pawn
i didn't consider that
not good my g6 is coming um
uh what to do
i'll be down only be down the exchange
i might just resign
uh white's played this well
but you never know
oh interesting
oh let's play
this point i don't care about my my b
pawn
eight moths hoping for this move
oh eight moths thank you hey bobo bagans
welcome back
eight moths as opposed to butterflies
let's go good to see you
um maybe this move
so i was threatening b5 now i have i
just want to uh make a pass pawn and
then make a queen
and then hope that white blunder's a
rook
okay threatening this now
um my rook is stuck
let's move up the king
you never know weird things can happen
sometimes
i'm about to get mated though
don't mean me so if takes i fork oh i
got muted okay
i tried to be tricky there oh i'm
playing a very high rate of
was title player or maybe not
okay play one of these
play this i looked this up um
not too long ago
okay going for this move
so this is a kind of weird london
i'm trying to make work i guess i'll
castle
oops okay that didn't work
that really didn't work
oh that last game flustered me but thank
you vanquishrem
for the the sub
of this move trying to win the pawn
i just want something for the exchange
wow
very clever
g5 is a legal move
g5 is still probably a threat i could
play h4
which is like just very unusual f3
maybe h4 i'm just trying to confuse my
opponent
opponent's not confused
okay i'm just going to play down the
exchange
i'm not resigning because there's no
open files so the rooks have yet to be
involved that's a good move though okay
now there's open vials but black has a
slightly weak pawn
yeah i just want to attack the pawn rook
f2
i improve further
pawn can't be defended really but yeah
there's this counter attack
play this move first just trying to hold
my ground
now this move
box playing this well
i'm not seeing the knockout blow though
[Music]
this move coming
so i do have a pawn for the exchange
i might be threatening this too
yeah it's far from over
that's a good move this
no i can't do that i have to take
yeah that's closer to over
it's still tricky because my knights can
help
help the queenside pawns advance
my pawn
how to do this
i gotta make way for the c pawn
it's coming to e5 or not
it's turning into a race
this move down on time though
let's control e2
also c2 so the rook has a hard time
being relevant interesting
okay so i attacked the pawn and i
control d6 i'm threading this now
a fascinating position
okay now
so if ever it takes a pawn by fork
i just remove black's most dangerous
pawn might be threatening this
ah
no there goes my pawn
oh well played
still meet me please okay i resign
ah okay that was a close fight
i feel like i had some chances just
didn't manage my time well enough
got into trouble early okay
life goes on staffer gambit
staffer gambit
but okay saffron accepted let's go
most people playing bishop e2 yeah now
there's this
this this okay we're gonna go into the
magical
jonathan transline greatness
so g3 queen f6
see how much my opponent knows all still
theory
yeah so far we're following the famous
game between
stockfish was white and jonathan trance
was black
and oh no my knight and bishop but white
can only take one at a time
um i do have to remember this
i assume it's this
and then ah what's the move rook h2
yeah this line this is actually a cool
line
stockfish miss evaluates the sign
rook g1 and then queen h4 got this show
em what you're made of yeah by the way
it's coach kilo now
oh coach kilo oh cool thanks coach kilo
so this position stockfish says like
plus five for white i think
um but lilo will say like maybe closer
to plus two
and the point is it's it's really hard
for white to do much because the king is
always aligned
i'm going to have control over the d
file there's many cases where
wait a minute i can just take here yeah
there's cases where white's position
just crumbles really quickly
um
i'm not seeing the wind though i mean
rook d i could castle queenside too
i think i should start by casting
we should know i'm still down two pieces
i might end up sacking more for the
lulls
like takes and then push
there's knight a3 though
bishop e4 it's so close to winning man
how'd you do this
there's queen g5
g5 takes and then g2
not sure about this but it looks
interesting
we might get actually a playable
position for both sides
wow king d3
straw
limited knowledge of russian
what is this
and this is what i get for playing a
stafford
takes takes and then push
i could just move back
okay let's move let's just simplify
a little bit oh there's king takes
okay so bishop's pinned
so we're gonna get this position okay
it's playable
spent a lot of time there but i can't
complain here
just have to move quickly queen can come
from behind
king c2 expected
we trade i'll put the queen here
pressure the pawn always play king b8
and now pressuring the pawn
making loofs kind of
okay
f6 might happen
now i can bring the king in
i might i can't check
i could though
now let's play this
i'm going to take a work of magic to win
this
even draw this
it's making safe free moves
it's a free bishop
okay now it should be winning i didn't
calculate this though
no i'm losing ah what a game
well the game man
i think we were both trying to dirty
flag each other i shouldn't have sacked
the rook for the night
oh what a game that was a cool game a
school opening
um it was like cutting edge stafford
theory too
what to do i played this opponent before
i think i beat this opponent previously
car was hard to catch
okay play one of these
no that was a mouse slip okay i'll just
treat this as
all part of the game plan
um i usually don't do this
play queen e2
um i could take actually
let's take here first
take this way maybe e4 coming
there is e5 so maybe 95.
okay it is kind of a choir game
with opening
yeah more positional london opening
i'll probably castle queens or kingside
um probably have to trade
interesting can play this move
so black has two center pawns but i i
still have my pawns controlling the
center
so i don't mind this
there's a small trap if queen here i win
the night
oh even though maybe it would get messy
okay black's running this so nifty
so let's be careful this is a classical
idea
i just want to play king g2
actually the plan is probably king g2 h4
h5
to open the h file and then eventually
made on h8
this might come
also who is this from hungary
oh ghoulia pop i'm aware of that name
okay so if it takes
i might just uh keep all the tension and
take with rook
getting ready for h5
uh i think i'm winning a pawn now
oh i'm not because queen c6 so tricky
very tricky king h2
i'll start with this
well why not here i play this move
it's hard to crack the position
[Music]
i don't entirely know what i'm doing
but i'll try and pretend
what's my plan defend the pawn first
hmm
i really don't know what i'm doing
i guess i have to move around maybe play
c4 at some point turning this now
the king can never take on h6 at least
right now that sends me no sense
uh play this move
yeah i'm going for the squeeze
right now we have another file to work
with
intrude via a66
i don't want to draw though
here i can take or even better probably
takes that way
it's getting so confusing
okay tactics work kind of
oh kind of not though but maybe
i'm down with time
no
ah
no
watch it watch it watch it yes okay
i was flagging so i had to set up the
stomate trap let's go
i didn't lose that i was playing for a
win like the whole game
but that's that's another one to add to
the collection because it's the only way
to draw when i'm
solo on time okay next game
a good trick to know okay
playing oh oh i'm playing uh this is
venezuela right or no who is this
i feel like i was roommates with this
person in spain
yeah jose raphael gascon etc
let's play a6 here
um
yeah we played the tournament in vanasky
i didn't know him but um
they gave me like organizers gave me
free hotel
and um
yeah he was
what year was it 2019 he got his like
final gm norm at the tournament too
i didn't realize he was uh he was
streaming or has a youtube channel too
okay let's stay focused and try and show
no
mercy this move
it looks really passive i'm just trying
to trade stuff
if here i can play this move
he's very strong player but um i guess
blitz rating
maybe he's just slower on the clock so
i'm going to try and use time to my
advantage
gee don't mind the position whoa dj snot
boogie
the um yeah the snot buggy is back thank
you for
gifting subs there's knight f4 here
which probably doesn't work there's also
bishop g4
i play bishop g4 i was trying to
calculate um
here takes i think it's okay
it might just be a big trade
there's also this move yeah not a four
[Music]
way knight of four it's kind of
interesting actually
take six
can you play the english oh maybe
if i remember thank you mama05
i could play in english but i might
forget
we'll see oh and robert e continuing the
subgift they got from are we supposed to
thanks robert e and deblum gifting to
hidden bush 64.
so this move i'm really just trying to
confuse my opponent but the idea is to
take
oh this probably just doesn't work at
all
i thought i was being clever i could
take this way too
yeah i was only calculating knight takes
but queen takes is playable
okay i have to take this way so i'm down
the piece but there is pressure
in various directions and this might be
a threat
i'm playing playing very aggressive
style this game
oh there was a hype train earlier so i
don't think it's actually possible to
start one
but who knows okay rookie three good
move
rookie 3 very good move
if we trade
i just want to have fun always play r3
what wait what
uh knight h3 take sticks i might play
knight h3 here actually
it's probably no good but
i'm just trying to get a time scramble
at this point
so king f1 is probably the safest move
confusing position
[Music]
i mean king of f1 will take and play
rookie eights
there's also this line uh
wow rook h3 probably
beginning second trimester hey happy
birthday kind of
happy trimester birthday thank you b
waned
or pre-birthday i should say
um yeah this is actually working out
really
better than expected can i hear coming
probably
and save the rook so i have a rook and a
pawn for the two mongers
the minor pieces are a little bit
awkward here
rookie ones playable
i can't quite
do what i want okay let's just move
quickly
g6 coming
um dr bishop
don't hurt me oh that was a free queen
too
i thought opponent was trying to hurt me
let's go oh opponent resigned in the
time like it was two seconds to four
seconds
unexpected resignation very kind though
i guess
opponent blunder the queen which i yeah
i wasn't taking three queens there
that was a messy game okay
oh i forgot to play in english my
deepest apologies but we're having a fun
line of the london
which i'm kind of happy to see
yeah this is going to be maybe more
solid positional i think you credited
lime
good game for all the bits
yeah that was that was a weird game i
kind of went insane sack pieces and
managed to not flag
should save the knight threatening a
fork
so how about let's make a goal to finish
in top 100
which is not easy to do in arena kings
it's a good move to trade
there is an interesting idea of knight
t2 and c4
to try and get the fork
a little bit hopeful there
f6
f6 bishop e3 otherwise if the rook moves
then c4 should win a piece
you're such a gentleman eric refusing to
take your opponent's queen at least
twice yeah uh
i know the pain of losing a queen so i
didn't want to inflict pain on my
opponent
at least in in that regard
okay bishop g5 back maybe
a weird another weird game
so we'll trade i'll play c4 d5
also just play this
some idea knight g5 i don't mind if we
trade
and bishop here i play this attack the
ninth run this with a fork
okay it looks like that's what's going
to happen box in a sec
i mean black has to give up the exchange
here
this cool idea knight c4 and then oh
there's also rook c1
so yeah that's a better move
this move so if we trade queen e6 live
[Music]
pin
and this pawn is probably a goner but it
is preventing the knight from retreating
this way
if knight retreats this way i play queen
d5 and there's no bishop c6
there's this move i hit the knight
so i'll go for let's
be solid first
go for defile pressure
the idea is to play this
if this i play this
um i don't know what to do just keep
moving quickly though
high level problem solving with
diaphysical consequences
yeah whatever that means okay
lot gave me a free night there that was
nice let's go
thanks gigahertz for the the high level
problem solving
bits wait physical consequences
okay playing lower rated player than
usual so
i'll try and play even more aggressively
this game
but that might be difficult i play this
line
it's like a gambit variation
okay playing ultra ultra aggressively
i don't entirely know what i'm doing
it is nice though because white's going
to have a hard time
castling
oh never mind like in castle already
um i might be the one having a hard time
castling
or maybe both of us
okay and getting a reasonable position
so i want the castle queen side
be ready to attack on the king side
play king v8 first why can't castle
until a2 is defended
one plan is to play this this this
thank you hoffman haha slaving with
prime
i don't think white still wants a castle
here because queen a2
like whichever way white castles i'm
ready to attack
if the king stays in the center i'm
ready to do things in the center as well
if this c3 that weakens d3
okay so let's start with this
i might include knight d4 as a kind of
intermediate move
like takes knight d4
oh
almost trapping the bishop
but not quite
yeah i want to punish this move but i
don't see how
[Music]
i should try and target d3
i didn't see how though i'm going for
the slower build up
a4 might happen yeah
okay staying solid
if this takes i have a choice
i think i'd take with rook
just to keep the battery
so it's pretty clear white's not casting
queen side with the pawn so far pushed
well i do another game against twitch
chat yeah um we have the bots set up
again
so i think i can do it whenever actually
if i'm not mistaken i just have to
read the instructions
but there's a way to set it up
but now i still have to stay focused
it's not a bad move can take take some
knight d4
oh like c5 is a threat
i don't really want to take that
but maybe i do get some initiative
at this point it's probably just about
flagging
uh flagging my opponent okay let's go
for
this and then this
and it's still a fun position have the d
file
the light will come to d4 hopefully
um
let's take this
no just no time for white
i feel like this is how a car beats me
like he just plays really confidently
quickly
as long as you don't get mated you can
win on time
but hircaro also just wins on the board
too okay
next game lich pop thanks for subbing
for two months in advance
and parsnip nip oh i'm playing um
what's his name what to play
i'm playing ben feingold that's his name
uh let's play something normal
okay f6 on move two against ben feingold
because
for the content i know this move
so he's playing kind of a london type
thing
i have this move
i like this position
okay ben beat me like a previous arena
kings
so it's time to get revenge hopefully
i just want to play quickly
defend the pawn enjoy the nice center
i don't think i've ever played f6 so
early against ben
i have the f6 spam emote
and ben has the never play f6 emote
weird move if here i play bishop b8
okay now i'll just crush the knights
hopes and dreams
and probably the next several moves will
be like simple improving moves
almost certainly king h8
first and then bishop e6 because then if
knight g5
i have bishop g8
maybe i can win connect four or connect
five sometimes you must always play
f6 yes
or all the time
okay this is looking very very pleasant
can i take and play this oh it's almost
working
not quite working though
g5
it's such a pleasant position though
i just want to savor it okay i'll play
this move
defending the pawn bring the queen in
yeah i'm going to try and squeeze
a squeeze of fine gold but how
maybe move back
in this move first or this move
i should really be playing quicker we're
not going to trade because i have more
space
some g5 idea yeah just preventing f4 i'm
going to get ready to
push more pawns
hitting this pawn
whoa resilience thank you for the money
oh it's money
the more you donate the more you learn
that's a direct quote from ben by the
way
oh he wants to hurt me like the truth
uh
wait what's being attacked let's defend
everything
i'll lose a pawn because
donating to charity
i just want to trap a bishop oh also
this pawn's still hanging
and this all the pawns are hanging
as long as i have a time advantage
that's what's
most meaningful in life
he's very hesitant to play f3 i wonder
why
uh okay let's push
f3 is coming almost certainly
just do it then do it and what else does
white play
i actually don't know what i'm doing
against f3
i can play um i just want to trap the
queen
h4 g4 etc
mainly etc and too many feingoldisms
i take this
oh wait my queen's defending the knight
uh play this move
how to do this this move
up on time threatening this now
i'll have this move the skewer
it's still not over
queen's not quite trapped
but the pawns are rolling
like bowling balls
okay what a game that was a funny game
thanks for the game ben oh
f6 on move two
okay oh i'm playing um i'm playing my
roommate
my long forgotten roommate i'm playing
all the famous people this tournament
that's crazy i don't even know eric's
rapper oh he plays this and this
i actually knew that oh a6 is new
maybe he's been studying his openings
okay um
e4 is a main idea i might play it
immediately
and then queen e2
and queenie two and castling eric's
pretty good at chess
have this move too
yeah we might get some more kind of
positional game
not exactly what i was hoping for
yeah i'm not happy here it should be
close to equal
but it's going to be difficult to play
i'm down a ton of time too
uh hangs upon
unless it doesn't
i just castle and then go for d5
takes takes
i don't know what i'm doing play this
move
safer i really have to avoid a time
scramble
i just hung upon
maybe it's not so bad but maybe it is
b3
b3 would be the idea b3 queen a3 d5
i should probably just play b3 i should
go for this setup
it's really not too bad
okay
yeah the pawns want to be on light
squares
okay time is leveling out the king wants
to come in
that was probably a blunder because rook
f8
it's still interesting though
so i was thinking rook b8 here
i'm gonna be slightly worse it's maybe
not too bad but time
time is becoming more relevant
go for the trade
guaranteed trade
with some eventual d5 perhaps
rook d2 b3
he's so fast and time scrambled so have
to keep the time advantage
that was tricky
okay focus focus
king should be here
g4 i think it's okay
a little bit shaky
oh no my thing
don't make me don't hurt me
let's go another another one of those
let's go
let's go i feel so dirty i feel so dirty
where's my hand sanitizer
here's my hand sanitizer okay
let's go it's the second time this
tournament
yeah it's all about putting the king in
the corner let's go
oh hi irene hope you had a good night's
sleep
shout out to irene okay
man heart was heart was beating fast
palms were sweaty but palms are now
sanitized
okay i was looking for the berserk
button
hot dirty bits oh yeah thanks for that
okay another london i appreciate all the
love and support
thanks everyone for believing in me not
enough eric you now have to shower in
pure hand sanitizer
oh i might require
um a special type of shower
or more yeah that might require several
more models of these
anyway um i'm gonna stay focused
i'm top hundred let's go
um i did i think lose my streak but
we have a nice london opening
okay yeah like on one hand i'm a little
bit disappointed i didn't
win that because i was losing on time or
i was
winning on time um
on the other hand i'm happy i didn't
lose that
because i don't know what i'm saying
let's focus
like i could have won that i could have
lost it maybe a draw was a fair result
okay
i'm playing too slowly this game because
i'm so flustered from the the previous
game
uh i'll play king here the plan is to
play g4
and maybe go in even though the position
kind of closed down
i still do want to attack
and g4 is like the main way to try and
open things up
you can take okay this could be
very quick if takes it's made in two
takes this way then i'm threatening
maiden three
rest in peace chess brows mouse after
that stalemate
oh yeah rest in pieces
but respect eric for like completely
outplaying me
despite the time deficit because i
really thought it should have been an
easy win on time but
he's super tricky
yeah so this move prolongs the game
position is very nice though
okay
okay that was nice
let's keep playing aggressively staffer
gambit maybe
uh what is this
d3 f4
um i'm already baffled
it looks playable though i'm just going
to play quickly and
hope this works it might not work
it takes i have knight d4
okay i mean it's a type of position i'm
kind of happy about
because i have early initiative i am
down a pawn but
um yeah this is like a very kind of
typical gambit type position
i think i just castle here
and then go for the e-file attack
there's a lot of moves to choose from
here
and bishop v5
looks pleasant hitting the queen and
then preparing this
bishop here
and it looks so close to just completely
winning
f5
i five almost traps a queen i might play
a five
just get another thing doing something
if here and then i move back
yeah the queen is safer there
yeah maybe i just kind of chill
okay now i want to take oh it looks so
much fun
i can prepare it though i can play this
first
probably preparing to take oh
i forgot about that move i mean white's
king is should be
in much more danger than my king
okay now maybe takes this way
hesitating too much
i wasn't sure
down a lot of time like every move i'm
taking too much time
there's so many fun things to calculate
and i think the big problem for white is
the fact that the
the rook can't get in it's really hard
to connect the rooks
okay d2 so plan is clear maybe it takes
now
yeah i'm just trusting intuition because
if takes takes b2 is attacked
king moves this way then there's
discoveries
um
okay leaving the night attacked
maybe not the best decision
very risky play my time is low
i might just lose this and the hope is
this move
okay
the king's safe as long as this diagonal
stays covered
go in for the kill okay now it's
completely winning
oh wait no it's not completely winning
wait ah i didn't see that move
check no it's not legal should check
i'm not seeing it
ah that's really bad no
ah no
all my hope
oh my time ah i've gotten i could take
my my bishop
what to do okay playing pop attack
i am staying over 2600
okay i'm tilted now
okay not getting the england gambit trap
unfortunately
um but white didn't really punish me for
playing such a dubious opening
thank you your mom's brownies soothing
the pain with bits
okay
how much time is left 24 minutes left
i'll try and finish strong
in 64th place 35 tournament points
karu destroying everyone
um that's possible to maybe
try a quick climb
king should be here
trading a lot
um i have to watch out for stuff
mainly backrank
this is playable
if b5 i play knight d8 and i think most
things are defended
b5 is a bigger threat
thanks to thornen and for my sub gift
oh thank you thornenin
wait what oh three month gift just
wait gift subscription from thornenin
oh that's really kind whirlwind orb
entering month two that's cool
okay um i'm probably slightly worse here
but
maybe it's not so bad e4 is a good move
go for f5 maybe maybe not
probably want to maneuver the knight to
e6
also the possibility of walking the king
all the way up
[Music]
let's hold my ground so with f4 and now
i have g4 as a
possibility for the knight
we could end up repeating actually
yeah we might repeat here
i don't think i'll repeat because i'm up
on time
white's not repeating either okay so i
think we're both playing for a win
now i have slightly worse structure but
slightly more time
this move
cheer 500 oh oh good try
trying to cheer and resub at the same
time hey it's gg road
gg road i pretty sure i know in real
life
i met when i was like a child
uh and we attended chess camp in florida
right i think thanks for the oh thanks
for the 500 bits
making the cheer work
um can i take taking actually looks
nice because after it takes i have a
defended pass pawn
i'm still a little bit stuck
but i'll try and make this work maybe
knight h6 coming
probably gonna win on time
oh a7 is hanging um
okay now it should be winning
[Music]
actually it's weird i'm gonna win on
time
when the knight two oh that's not good
to take though
because queen b7
uh-oh i messed this up
check
this move no how to do this look this
way
ah okay
i shouldn't lose this this might be a
draw though
no no
that's a draw
oh only chess it would have been
declared a win
also in fiji it would be declared a win
because the knight is mating material
when the opponent has
at least a pawn
okay let's play e4 new opening
what a finish okay maybe that makes up
for some of the
the dirtier draws i had earlier
oh it's such a big time advantage it's
unfortunate
okay so playing b stock
playing a grand prix attack
this is my first e4 game as white
okay play this
oh oops most people take with pawn
i was not expecting knight takes so i'm
losing a pawn here
it's not so bad damage the structure
put the queen in the center treating
this like a gambit
attack this and this is really not too
bad
hey tillisman from indonesia slamat
how do you say morning good morning
good morning
um i was gonna try and learn indonesian
so i was in indonesia a couple years ago
yeah i thought that might see you later
but maybe not
okay i'm gonna focus on the chess
so i want c6 i can win oh i can do fancy
things
look at this takes if takes i discover
fork and if that i
i say oh no my queen and then i win this
okay that was nice
playing yavjani was this
russian grand master oh tomaszewski
strong player
so queen's gambit declined
okay a6 is kind of a pet line
but i'm still prepared here
oh
[Music]
so i delayed c6 because in this case uh
usually c5 maybe b5 first
but eventually c5
[Music]
tricky play from the i opponent
i'll play bishop b7 some idea knight e4
ah rook c there's bishop f5
so i can play this move ah but then i
lose a pawn
i have to do this there's 94.
we trade i think it's okay
because i defend the pawn light
supported
thanks people for the bits appreciate
that
have this move
trading makes me more comfortable
especially against gm's now i can play
maybe
this but then takes takes
i just lose a pawn
so this move knight c6
we trade in rookie six
or even better we trade in knight f2
okay
yeah it's hard to play c5 here
this move is going after this pawn
oh what to do
g5 i don't know what to do i'm probably
going to lose this pawn eventually
i'll try and be solid
before maybe
[Music]
a very difficult position so if takes i
went f2
down a lot of time
i'm just trying to hold my ground oh i
lost a pawn
good move have this move
yeah actually i didn't think i mind this
in balance but maybe i do
because this pawn is going to be so
strong
i can keep kicking around the rook
ah there comes the c5
yeah before
i have to try this
i just want to get the pawn to b3
and threadmate this doesn't work though
but maybe i'm turning perpetual
so d7 i check
i think that's perpetual i don't know
though king a2
that's not perpetual
it was worth a try
time to resign
time to resign good game
yeah i got all played it was like the
one pawn the backwards c pawn really uh
was painful but uh life goes on
good positional lesson oh i'm playing is
this minlae i think this is minlae
uh let's play d4
oh i think he plays london himself
i wonder he's um yeah maybe we've gone
into this line before
love the content oh i love you too thank
you credited
and truckers for life my credit to lime
i thought you summed like
an hour ago but maybe not maybe you just
cheered
thank you uh for subbing
um bishop e6 good move
i gotta play much quicker i mean
probably knight d2
[Music]
looks passive but what else to do
another good move okay i want to play e4
probably
or not i just want to like steadily
improve the position
[Music]
maybe knight c4 if the timing's right
d oh the letter of
um yeah whatever that emoji is this a
free pawn
that's a free pawn
thank you snail conglomerate and evan
adolf
thank you for gifting five subs
appreciate that
um okay let's stay focused
move all the way back it's a good
position
just a little bit down on time
put the rook back somewhere more useful
he's being resourceful before
i'm just trying to shift the focus to
the queen side
so there's some nice alignment with the
king
bishop here maybe e4
kind of invites f4 but
this might work in some lines
you can take with rook 2
9 f6
so i want to keep the pressure here
let's keep building up
so if takes i i win the queen
it's still alignment oh and i'm
threatening to probably take
not sure how great that is i might just
put the rook on g4
interesting so we have to
do this
okay it's getting a little bit weird i'm
still up a pawn but
black has some space
now here i can take the bishop
yeah i should have probably maybe never
mind
oh it's still weird though let's go for
this
ah if takes i take the bishop first
i think
threatening rook b7 rook b6
i have to stay calm
i didn't think this works 97 okay that
move
um that's still playable
a king f5i fork here we go
threatening this
okay can always sock the bishop
my time though
oh no oh that's not what i wanted
i can trade queens
let's go oh what just happened there
let's go let's go okay
oh man that was a good fight that was a
good fight
okay the competition doesn't get easier
though
man okay this is maybe the last game
or last full game
so i gained some rating there that was
nice
and this is what i need to do to finish
in the top 100 in the tournament
really not easy okay gonna go for
kind of the classic bishop d3 and e4
um
[Music]
there's cases where h7 could be oh
that's a tricky move i wonder if i can
play bishop a4 because if takes i win
the bishop and otherwise
there should be five and then i lose a
pawn
i might be in trouble here
yeah i think i'm in kind of big trouble
because i can't castle either way
there's 94.
and the plan might be to try and castle
queenside
this bishop is so strong
oh i'm losing a pawn
queen g4
[Music]
i might never mind oh i can castle
kingside
okay i'm alive i think
yeah i'm alive
um
i have to play f3 not so pretty
but it's playable
probably take and try and trade
everything
i mean generally queen and knight is
preferable for queen and bishop 23.
i have the c5 square for the knight too
i'm throwing a spike check
probably not a great move have this move
time
maybe this move
nah okay
this should be a draw but who knows all
three results are possible
the game might actually get aborted if
we go the full distance
okay so now i'm threading the pawn with
chuck
ah very sneaky let's hide the king
so either pawn is take and i i take on
b5
the key might try and meet me
i have a4 here
it's getting spicy
ah that sounds scared me i don't know
why that was so scary
let's find maiden one
oh that didn't work
oh yeah it's gonna be a draw
i just have to not flag
or it's gonna get aborted um i think
draw because there's no time left
oh i hung up on wait that was not called
for
i'll watch this so i'll set up a sneaky
snail matrix
oh never mind okay i was waiting for
black to take the pawn i was gonna sack
my queen
but uh okay good job hakaru
winning my carl's gotta be like the
arena kings um god of
winning so many of these tournaments but
uh that was fun
had some fun games had a lot of uh
interesting opponents i played the karu
we had a cool game
i played ben feingold played min lei
eric hansen played a lot of famous
people this tournament
man but there there are a lot of fun
games in this one
two uh two of these like dirty stalemate
traps
one against eric hanson so that was fun